so the question is what is the most
deadly bacterial disease
in the world well it is the
mycobacterium
tuberculosis which causes the disease
tuberculosis or tb
now tuberculosis is very very
interesting i had no idea it killed
1 million 800 000 people every single
year worldwide
that is incredible but what's more
incredible is i found out that 25 of the
population has been infected with tb but
not in its active form okay in its
dormant or latent form so there's two
forms of tb you have the
active infection and then you have like
an infection that's in remission or it's
called latent and it kind of sits there
and it doesn't actually cause any
symptoms at all and it's not even
infectious you can't spread tb when it's
dormant or when it's latent now this is
what you need to know
not a large percent
of tb is active okay
like ninety percent is latent and only
five to ten percent
becomes active but the problem with this
is that 50
of people with an active infection that
are not treated actually die so it is
very very deadly but my question of
course is
what about the other 50
why
do they live what do they have
special about them that helps them
survive well it's something that i
couldn't really find a lot of
information on you see what's really
missing when you deal with infections is
your own immune system that seems to be
neglected and instead we focus more on
the antibiotics and other treatments
which i'm going to get to but for people
that have an active tb infection
they usually have a chronic cough and
they might have some mucus that has some
blood in it
they have a fever they get back pain
they lose weight they might have night
sweats and they might just have these
mild symptoms for months and another
unique thing about tb is that
apparently
it takes eight to ten weeks before it
even shows up on a test so you might be
infected but not really know it for
weeks now a big problem with the
treatment of tb is
you're given multiple
antibiotics for months and months and
months and the problem is that you might
be at risk for getting antibiotic
resistance okay like 13
of the people who get treated become
resistant to the antibiotic and then it
doesn't work at all so then what are you
going to do
and apparently six percent of population
is resistant to
any treatment you do for tb so i want to
share something interesting about these
antibiotics
there's some things you need to know
number one antibiotics do not
do anything for viral infections okay
they don't do anything for
fungal or yeast or candida infections
and 60
of all antibiotic treatments have been
shown to be unnecessary because a lot of
these infections were viral or fungal or
yeast infections and a really big
complication of this is antibiotic
resistance because then you start
developing these super bugs i mean the
same exact thing is happening in
agriculture when you're killing off
these microbes in the soil you start to
get super bugs and then now you have a
problem with these pathogens that are
very very difficult to kill and just as
an important side note if you ever take
an antibiotic always take a probiotic at
the exact same time okay and then
afterwards you don't want to wait until
you're done with the round of
antibiotics
and if you're taking a probiotic that is
not going to interfere with the
effectiveness of the antibiotic okay
it's not going to prolong the infection
because you're not taking pathogens
you're taking
probiotics that means you're taking
friendly
microbes and when people have antibiotic
resistance
they're very vulnerable to getting a
secondary infection and that's primarily
going to be like a yeast infection a
candida infection that's going to have
this overgrowth you see the bacteria are
there to keep the yeast in check and so
as soon as you wipe them out you get
this
overgrowth and that creates a whole
series of issues
another really major side effect of
antibiotics is brain side effects i'm
talking about
cognitive
loss of memory
uh brain fog
confusion
psychosis
major depression
anxiety
irritability so you'll have mood changes
and cognitive changes now there's
something else that's very interesting
about tb that i want to share with you
i talked about the active form in the
latent form and usually if someone's
going to get the active form of tb it's
going to be within one to three years
however
they could get it later in life okay but
the percentage
of you getting it becomes less and less
so what would increase your risk of
getting it down the road well
if you live in the northern hemisphere
you're more at risk also you're at more
risk during the winter months so what's
common about these two items right here
and if you guessed low vitamin d you are
correct because vitamin d deficiencies
increase your risk
of in the active form of tb by five
times and so there's a very strong link
between vitamin d
and tb and that's simply because vitamin
d is
the most important vitamin for your
immune system it affects almost every
part of your immune system and it helps
to regulate the immune system and if
you're low in vitamin d
you're greatly susceptible to not just
tb but a lot of other infections and now
also i found some interesting
information about the vitamin d receptor
okay there's this genetic problem with
vitamin d called polymorphism where the
receptor for vitamin d
just won't accept the vitamin d it's
kind of resistant okay
and so if you have this genetic defect
you're going to be more susceptible to
getting tb
and more and more people are
getting assessments for their dna and
there's a lot of great information you
can find from that by the way various
weaknesses that you can then strengthen
epigenetically also people that have
post traumatic stress syndrome
are more likely to get tb why because it
activates cortisol
so stress activates cortisol which not
only lowers your vitamin d but cortisol
in general
paralyzes your immune system this is why
so many people develop autoimmune
conditions
and all sorts of
weird strange illnesses right after
major stress events especially losses
now a couple other things that will
increase the risk of this infection
age as you get older of course
as you get older
your vitamin d goes down and your immune
system goes down chemotherapy destroys
the immune system so that can also kick
in
an episode of active tb and then we have
steroids what's steroids
so steroids generally you know they're
anti-inflammatory but they put your
immune system into a sleep mode and this
comes back to why vitamin d is the most
important vitamin for your immune system
and also why you need to be out in the
sun a lot more get sun exposure not to
the point of getting burned
but
just before that okay sun is very very
healthy not just for the vitamin d but
for the
infrared and even the uv spectrum is
actually good for certain things as well
because uv can actually deactivate
certain pollutants in the air as well as
as well as microbes as a maintenance
dosage i would recommend
about 10 000 ius of vitamin d3
and in addition to that if you have
tb
or you're feeling run down i would beef
that up to about 30 to 40 000 iu's for a
period of time now if you haven't seen
my video on the
relationship between the sun and your
immune system i put that right here
check it out
you